Farzana Iqbal was stoned to death here
outside the High Court building in
Lahore allegedly by members of her own
family
police say the 25 year old and her
husband were waiting for the court to
open when around a dozen men attacked
her with bricks the local police chief
said she was killed because she refused
to accept an arranged marriage with her
cousin she married the man she loved her
parents filed an abduction case against
them they were here for their case in
the High Court the incident happened on
their way to court her family stoned her
to death
lisanna suffered severe head injuries
and was taken to hospital but was
pronounced dead on arrival
her husband escaped injury Farzana is
said to have been three months pregnant
police say her father two brothers and
former fiance were among the attackers
her father turned himself in to the
police saying the killing was a matter
of Honor Pakistani authorities say
nearly nine hundred women were murdered
in so-called honour killings in 2013
human rights groups say many cases go
unreported and the real number may be
much higher